Spider-Man across the spider-verse has
swung into theaters and we're here on
City Walk on the street asking folks how
do you like the movie this video
contains spoilers you have been warned
[Music]
what movie did you just see
it's Monumental it's absolutely
phenomenal fever dream for Spider-Man
fans 10 out of 10 amazing it's
spectacular it's ultimate it's
everything that's been described as
Spider-Man over to Comics over the years
it's amazing oh my gosh that's gonna be
the Oscar winner for sure I doubt
there's going to be another film that
tops this this movie felt like The
Empire Strikes Back of all Spider-Man
movies this is one of my top Spider-Man
films for sure this is the best
Spider-Man movie ever one of the best
Spider-Man movies ever made I'ma one-up
that it is the best Spider-Man movie out
there you know what I'm gonna let him
have that one it's just a 10 out of 10
for me it's good is it your favorite
movie
yes thank you for your bravery reading
next
the animation was just amazing the
Artistry the look of it the feel of it
it was like really intense that time not
gonna lie it has a lot of really crazy
moments and you're kind of just sitting
there like did I just see that happen
silico was great about the first movie
and just elevated to the next level the
first one of these was so much of a game
changer that it was really concerning
how the second one was going to present
and they leveled up and they kept it
going I was really impressed every part
of this is like it's either really funny
really emotional or it's all the above
it just flows so nicely despite it being
a two and a half hour movie this is such
a beautiful film
struggles go through it it was a great
film did we get a little emotional in
that theater at least yeah yeah it's
just a little thing in there
at the end I really liked it it made me
just want to do some stuff
foreign
[Music]
probably one of the best introductions
into a movie that I've seen in the last
five ten years when he first enters
their headquarters there's hundreds of
Spider-Man and I was really taken aback
when I saw the T-Rex Spider-Man and I
started laughing so hard I have to say
the baby when she put the mask
I think the big chase in the middle was
really something spectacular the more
storyline with Gwen Stacy is just
amazing I think she just kind of becomes
another favorite new character when Gwen
was hugging her dad oh man that was it
for me right there are you about to cry
right now
don't send me we can on camera
you can cry on camera here it is
oh my God that's as good as Claire Danes
and I looked at my uncle and ah let me
guess he died
they show a lot of scenes from like all
different Spider-Mans every single
franchise and include references
everywhere and it's just great I love
Miles Morales I think he's a great
character and I loved where it's taking
the film I think it's going to be a
really exciting like ending that he knew
that he had enough strength to do what
he had to do nice he wasn't a wimp as
they thought he was I just didn't like
the ending it was like a really big
Cliffhanger oh man I'm so overwhelmed to
just see that to be continued by the end
it's like oh my god what the heck man
don't leave me off like that ever again
that's a direct threat to Spider-Man and
everybody in this movie do not upset
Micah don't upset Micah clearly he knows
they stop Spiderman
that's all for on the street and now we
want to hear from you let us know what
you thought of across the spider verse
is who the best Spider-Man movie ever
who's your favorite Spider-Man can't
wait to hear your thoughts after you see
the movie make sure you rate and review
at rottentomatoes.com Rotten Tomatoes is
not wrong
thanks bud get off my lawn how tall are
we running we're running six seven six
seven all right my God we'll be right
back with Rotten Tomatoes